okay so this is death and bloom it's
that the exact same shirt you wore last
time yes you like em what two shirts
that you go through four to five at most
okay yeah that's gross okay that same
hat you wore yes it is I only have one
so ha joke's on you that's you're gross
yeah especially since it's been on my
head don't touch it sorry sir okay so
this is death and bloom this is an
episode where they're looking after the
princess plant and they kill it exit
that way by doing all the things you
shouldn't do with a plant and they have
to go the world of the dead is a is that
the first time we saw a world of the
Dead
and it's really rockin it's like a
really cool place and they have to go to
death to get the soul of the plant back
and sure enough they do they bring it
back and it she just eats it and they
want to thank peppermint Butler because
he sent them to the world of dead and he
wants their flesh says he'll take it
while they sleep you know that would be
an awesome to be continued if that was
the next episode like while they're
sleepy he comes in and tries to get in
that's like the next like the Oh like
one of a few things that like carries
over like directly from the last episode
no I should that be hilarious it feels
like five episodes later or something
it'd be great maybe great so yeah I
really like this episode actually um
this is actually like maybe one of my
favorites I don't know what what it is
it's just for lack of a better word it's
just a cool episode the world is cool
and the death is like one of my new
favorite characters I love that guy I
love how just he doesn't give a crap
about anything but it's always stuff
about like killing you or getting your
soul just ya know that's a game come on
come on go kill you now come on don't be
a jerk you know it's just
and the whoever voiced is like really
great so I know the guy who voiced I'm
forgetting his name but uh he was in
Stephen King's The Stand he was in the
knight flyer he was in crossing Jordan I
haven't seen any of those things and
that's all he was in I bet no missing
he was in mourns I never spray it never
mind he was in the blank stare yeah in
case the blank stare cuz he can write a
book about just don't like some rednecks
in Maine and you got a movie but yeah I
really liked it there's just I love
seeing this world and it's not like it's
hard to explain cause it's not like the
best design world compared the other
worlds but there's just something about
I guess I like saw these weird creepy
underworlds it has like you know heavy
metal music going and stuff like that it
felt like I was in like an album cover
or something like a really cool album
cover
especially when death listening and like
the fires going and everything and I
love how sporadic it was to this one
seem especially I think just with the
reactions especially because I loved in
the opening when they're not treating
the plant well and there's nothing that
takes you know that singles them that
it's dead yeah you know you just look
it's like yeah good night little buddy
yeah
nothing singles it a night I just love
and it's so immediate and it's
immediately you know you get the
wrinkles are the I know he killed it and
that was great I love him stepping on
the skull of the skull they keep saying
to drink the water see which where do
dead skulls are already dead in the land
of the dead go hey well remember when
Jake killed a whole bunch of them you
double kill them there you go so they're
like a world of the dead for the world
of the Dead possibly we'll find out
maybe next episode definitely not next
episode but yeah I really liked it what
do you think no this is definitely one
of my favorites especially because I the
as the series goes along peppermint
Butler is just one of my favorite
characters and this shows a little bit
about him
oh you're talking about going to the
land of the dead I can take you there I
love the way they do it outside date to
drum I love the way they do where they
cross the eyes at the corner of the room
and that opens it up it's like in a
strange way that almost makes sense but
it doesn't but it almost does see a kid
you think like the magic guys and you
know I think those were made by the
devils so I
gets up yeah but no no I love the design
overall of death I love how there's just
or not death of the land of the dead how
there's just all these cop cars
everywhere yeah I don't know why there's
not any other type of vehicle it's just
a whole bunch of cop cars maybe maybe
can't I sit - the whole apocalypse thing
like maybe all the cops were trying to
like stop the apocalypse is I don't know
because anyone the apocalypse there'd be
a lot of bodies there so I know why that
would be but in the guard how'd you do
yeah God boy sounded so familiar to me -
oh that one I don't know offhand but
yeah I mean balanced a lair it's just
like you know he doesn't believe they're
dead he's like follow my lead and they
just want it that's like they're
sneaking in but they're in plain sight
it's just stop no stop nothing going oh
darn it yeah it's like there are times
we just wonder like in some places they
have like really bad security or like
low key security like you know yeah
could you just what they really do
anything but then I get into the Land of
the Dead how many non dead people come
down there I get I don't know you know
what else would you know he's probably
checking out I thought was pretty cool
he's probably not trained very well and
stopping living then is the dude smash
it what no okay his hands were pretty
small that's good oh good okay the point
where Jacob in says again just totally
sure that takes me back to like Brendan
Stimpy where it's just like it's so
weird and so surreal you just can't help
but giggle at it yeah strange it is it's
like it it does connect but just on the
most surreal basic just think of it it
could possibly happen level that's I
can't even explain it just it it maybe
deagle just the right way and it I
freaking love it I also love at the
beginning especially your reaction to
the initial title card yeah a real title
card you're just like wow wait a minute
I didn't expect that to happen at all
it's a good title card especially both
of them dead yeah
um and the we got returned the
watermelon Stanley I just so don't know
what the story of that is like you know
is it really like alive or is it just
just fruiting there and say it's like I
I don't really know it did somebody say
they're alive and it's just seeing how
long people go up with a Sharad I don't
know like somebody's like let's just see
if this will work and sure gnome like
the whole kingdom things it's a lie I
don't know but I think the only thing I
noticed that was I don't know if it's
odd or interesting or whatever but I
think unless I'm mistaken I think it's
the first episode where I saw bubblegum
like in a different dress and like she's
worn like whatever science coats and
some like that but it's like an actually
different outfit does that I think
you're right I think that's just the
first time she's officially changed oh
wait a minute someone have something up
screen to say what does she have to say
what about that one with the whole
lights up
wait wait wait don't hit the camera yeah
okay I know now look what about that one
with the tarts I remember she was
wearing like smelling his cake dress oh
yeah she was wearing the dress in the
yellow thing was like a cupcake
oh that's right okay so it's not the
first time they were wrong no no no but
even that wasn't her like a reasons I
guess this was percent you see where
it's lying friends well then again she
was going to that special thing where
she was going for Stanley and then
there's another conference that's true
we're probably thinking way too hard
about this but at the same time there's
a part of me that's just like yeah just
why a different race I go like that
different either like you know something
like the cupcake thing like sorry makes
sense guess it's so weird and why would
she wear that but this it's like just
kind of a different color it's like it's
like if Finn one day just more like a
slightly less blue shirt or something
you notice he wears his blue and he else
wears a yellow shirt doesn't yeah yeah
what do you want the yellow shirt well
in the first Ice King episode he's
wearing a yellow shirt where's the
yellow shirt okay so there's sometimes
they just change clothes I don't know
why that sounds strange to me Lucy it's
so funny because we clearly don't I mean
maybe that's why it's so odd to us when
we watch normal shows people change all
the times but when we watch like you
know the Flintstones or they're always
wearing the same things to another we're
seeing a show or to everyone to know how
they change it's like that's not right
man that's just not right I love not
even like the semi-realistic show is
like I mean for like what everyday like
still kitchen but like Disney or em I
think of gargoyles like you know you'll
have like the cop always has like the
exact same red jacket and like black
shirt it's like did you just have a
whole wardrobe of nothing so yeah no but
good catch I you know we miss that so
yeah okay what do you think the episode
what what do you think of the episode I
liked it okay gonna so yeah that's all I
got I thought was good yeah and again
peppermint Butler's one of my favorite
characters especially as it goes along
and I'm trying to remember mmm if it
happened before this or if it happens
after it doesn't give a huge lot away no
yeah I don't remember
um but there's one scene where
peppermint Butler's asking Finn and Jake
to help with a body he just happened to
find oh my god and it's done really fast
and it's done kind of really really
quick he's like Oh will you help me with
this body I just found like this and
it's just really really quick and yeah I
love peppermint Butler because I want to
know what he's hiding you know yeah
again something interesting about these
characters is almost none of these
characters maybe wanted to but so few of
them get an introduction yeah you know
like peppermint Butler's just you saw
some of the background he's kind of
there whatever and then it's just like
he's a character now ya know it's like I
know who he is I'm sorry giving a feel
for what he's like but it's like there
was no introduction of him even tree
trunks like didn't really like it wasn't
like who is this oh this is tree trunks
whatever they're just I don't like tree
trunks you make the best pies or whether
it's like don't you know who tree trunks
is everything is like don't you know who
this character is you should know yeah
and that's like it's just kind of
strangely refreshing it and it's funny
and so it's like you serve and it's fun
too because then you can find out how
much
they do know about the character and how
much is like its biggest surprise to
them as it is to us or yes oh no that's
just normal that's you know
peppermint Butler like they would just
expect that of him yeah but this episode
also talks a bit more about license
eight talks but brings up more about
eating flesh or human flesh yeah
certainly like a big zombie thing and
let's go back all the way to Episode one
with zombies yeah
remember starchy when he turns back he's
still trying to eat Finn when he says
uh-huh because you taste yummy oh you
taste delicious
was he peppermint or candy no will start
to us I think what would start CB I
don't know like maybe just puff ball
some food I don't know now a gravedigger
but there's that way um flesh-eating
thing going on here a motif yes so cool
wanting to scratch the noggins over so
uh that's it we'll see in the next one
- hey I'm ending on that